mass effect legendary edition is finally
here and i bet you're all
itching to see how the remastered
version of mass effect 1
compares to the 2007 original
we're gonna be doing just that showing
off a sample of each of the major
characters as well as the opening
section of eden prime and the citadel
if you guys enjoy this video and want to
see us compare later sections of the
game
make sure to leave a like and subscribe
if you haven't already
we are comparing the pc versions and
quick random fun fact
the original pc release of mass effect
had a strange quark where garrus's
high-res texture
was missing instead he only had his
low-res texture
so yes if you're wondering why it looks
so bad in the original
that's why alright thanks again for
watching and enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all stations secure for transit
[Music]
hitting the relay in three
two one
[Music]
you think the alliance brass is holding
out on us if all we're supposed to do
is test out the stealth system why is
captain anderson in charge
and then there's nihilus spectres are
elite operatives top covert agents
why send a spectre a turry inspector on
a shakedown run
it doesn't add up commander shepard i
was hoping you'd get here first it will
give us a chance to talk
what about i'm interested in this world
we're going to
eden prime i've heard it's quite
beautiful
i've never been there but you know of it
it's become something of a symbol for
your people hasn't it
proof that humanity can not only
establish colonies across the galaxy but
also protect them
but how safe is it really we don't know
what information was stored in that
beacon
lost prothean technology blueprints for
some ancient weapon of mass destruction
whatever it was
saran took it but i know saren
i know his reputation is politics he
believes humans are a blight on the
galaxy
this attack was an act of war gunnery
chief ashley williams of the 212.
you the one in charge here sir give me a
status report williams
we were patrolling the perimeter when
the attack hit
we tried to get off a distress call but
they cut off our communications
i've been fighting for my life ever
since settle down commander
you've already done more than enough to
jeopardize your candidacy for the
specters
the mission on eden prime was a chance
to prove you could get the job done
instead nihilus ended up dead and the
beacon was destroyed
that's seren's fault not his then we
better hope the csec investigation turns
up evidence to support our accusations
otherwise the council might use this as
an excuse to keep you are the specters
commander shepard garros vicari i was
the officer in charge of the c-sec
investigation into sarah
come across anything i should know about
saren's a spectre
most of his activities are classified i
couldn't find anything solid
but i know he's up to something like you
humans say i feel it in my gut
it is the decision of the council that
you be granted all the powers and
privileges of the special tactics and
reconnaissance branch of the city
spectres are not trained but chosen
individuals forged in the fire of
service and battle those whose actions
elevate them
above the rank and fire spectres are an
ideal a symbol
the embodiment of courage determination
and self-reliance
they are the right hand of the council
instruments of our will
spectres bear a great burden they are
protectors of galactic peace
both our first and last line of defense
the safety of the galaxy is theirs to
uphold
witnesses saw you making threats in
fist's bar
stay away from him i don't take orders
from you this is your only warning rex
you should warn fist i will kill him
you want me to arrest you i want you to
try
go on get out of here
do i know you human my name's shepard
i'm going after fist thought you might
want to come along
shepard commander shepard
i've heard a lot about you we're both
warriors shepard
out of respect i'll give you a fair
warning
i'm going to kill this fist knows you're
coming we'll have a better chance if we
all work together
my people have a saying seek the enemy
of your enemy
you will find a friend just set me up
i knew i couldn't trust him don't worry
about fist he got what was coming to him
then i guess there are two things i need
to thank you for
who are you my name's shepard
i'm looking for evidence to prove
saren's a traitor then i have a chance
to repay you for saving my life
but not here we need to go somewhere
safe we could take her to the human
embassy
your ambassador will want to see this
anyway
do you desire to learn of the in
kindlers or has the honorable sea sac
officer enlisted assistance what's going
on here
the sea sec officer request that this
one purchase an evangelical permit to
spread the truth of the end kindlers
my species is mono-gendered male and
female
have no real meaning for us we still
require a partner to reproduce
this second parent however may be of any
species and any gender
i don't understand your species can mate
with anyone
mating is not quite the proper term not
as you understand it
physical contact may or may not be
involved but it is not an essential
element of the union
the true connection is mental our
physiology allows us to meld with other
beings
we can touch the very depths of their
minds
engaging stealth systems
somebody was doing some serious digging
here captain
we are approaching drop point two
so
so
this isn't your mission saren what are
you doing here
the council thought you could use some
help on this one
i wasn't expecting to find the geth here
the situation's bad
look at the size of it
[Music]
[Music]
set the charges destroy the entire
colony leave
no evidence that we were here
[Music]
so
my god it's like someone dropped a bomb
that must be where the guests ship
landed
we identified the ship that touched down
on eden prime
the normandy a human alliance vessel
it was under the command of captain
anderson they managed to save the colony
and the beacon one of the humans may
have used
this human must be eliminated
[Music]
look at the size of that ship the
ascension
flagship of the citadel fleet well sizes
and everything
why so touchy joker i'm just saying you
need firepower too
look at that monster its main gun could
rip through the barriers in any ship in
the alliance fleet
good thing is on our side then citadel
control this is
ssv normandy requesting permission to
land stand by for clearance normandy
clearance granted you may begin your
approach transferring you to an alliance
operator
roger alliance tower
this is alliance tower please proceed to
dock four two
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to presidium tourism terminal 3.
here in the financial district a number
of businesses offer various goods and
services to their exclusive clientele
the statue you see before you was
commissioned to honor the krogan
soldiers who gave their lives to protect
citadel space during the rachni wars
in the aftermath of the krogan
rebellions several embassies petitioned
to have the statue removed
however this motion was eventually
quashed by the council
discovered by the asari who first
arrived at the citadel
the relay monument is one of the
station's most interesting and
controversial features
little is known about these peaceful
servants of the citadel
though they are essential to the
operation and maintenance of the entire
station
the council isn't going to ask me any
questions are they i got it we've made
our reports
now we just have to trust ambassador no
we don't sir
seren's hiding something
commander shepard garros vicari i was
the officer in charge of the csec
investigation into sarah
what's the sounds
you may be right first
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
this is commander shepard speaking we
have our orders
find sarin before he finds the conduit i
won't lie to you crew
this mission isn't going to be easy for
too long our species has stood apart
from the others
now it's time for us to step up and do
our part for the rest of the galaxy
time to show them what humans are made
of
when we go into the traverse seren's
followers will be waiting for us
but we'll be ready for them too humanity
needs to do this
not just for our own sake but for the
sake of every other species in citadel
space
sarin must be stopped and i promise you
all
we will stop well said commander
captain will be proud the captain gave
up everything so i could have this
chance
we can't fail yes sir